nous allons commencer enthousiasme
général nous allons remettre des prix ça
fait plaisir surtout à ceux qui les
reçoivent et puis quand on est un peu
gêné rodez content pour eux et puis on
cherche à les rencontrer
je vous demande accueillie aux
passionnés kate blanchet
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment extraordinaire bonne
ambiance entre nous 5 lui aussi je
souhaite prédire que je crois qu'elle ne
sera jamais plus le bienvenu ici chacune
10 prince d'avoir une communauté et à
toi même ceux qui l'ont jamais dénoncé
ces faits ce premier tome i et voilà on
devrait pointer de toit à cause de leur
comportement mais l'envers les 118 un
comportement indigne pour cette
industrie
un digne de n'importe quelle industrie
vous savez qui vous les plus importants
ou encore nous nous savons qu'une chose
à vous permettre de vivre dans
l'impunité est compliquée en tant que
père et sa malle il ya serait ma passion
féminine a comme un handicap
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
alors nous sommes là pour donner les
prix à la meilleure interprétation
masculine
madame le président nous voudrions
savoir qui a vous avez vous décidé de
donner cet important prix du match et la
fia
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors il faut l'accepter
moi je leur ai pris
non rien ici roberto il faut qu'ils me
je voulais dire que en étant plateau et
la casa mia
quand j'étais jeune et plus vous allez
la mienne et que des boyaux qui mènera
les hindous comme les yeux et on va y
aller
j'avais l'impression d'entendre des
champions et maintenant vos options
c'est nous qu'il aurait adoré et mater
matin pour la première fois dans
l'histoire du cinéma du festival jean
nous allons remettre un prix spécial à
jouer dimanche
alors vous n'êtes pas jean-luc godard
mais vous venez en son nom sans doute il
est en train de vous regarder sur son
portable
le pari fou de jean-luc godard en fait
style pendant le festival a été un
moment d'humour une poésie génial j'ai
déchiré lauréat du prix du jury acquis
50 du mar
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
merci infiniment pour ce prix inouïe
c'est une chance énorme pour un film qui
est un petit film qu'on a fait à la
maison en famille je crois profondément
au pouvoir du cinéma le cinéma n'est pas
seulement fait pour divertir pour faire
rêver il est aussi fait pour faire
réfléchir pour montrer l'invisible pour
dire ce qu'on peut pas dire on peut plus
continuer à tourner le dos est restée
aveugle à la souffrance de ces enfants
qui se débattent comme ils peuvent
dans ce capharnaüm qui est devenu le
monde aspire one
qu'est ce que je sens du monde
aujourd'hui qu'est ce que je ressens
quelle est ma vision du monde alors ma
réponse est que nous aimons tous le
cinéma et vous savez le film de peter
weir vivre dangereusement les lignes
c'est une heure c'est l'année de tous
les dangers
ats
[Applaudissements]
maintenant est ce time for the palme
d'or c'est intraduisible en français
indécise palme d'or et là pendant cette
année une case of 200 activités
sanguinaires deux petits garçons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
c'est assez correctement
j'avoue que j'ai quand même les jambes
qui tremblent un peu je demande
maintenant aussi à tous les records tous
les lauréats de nous rejoindre sur scène
pour l'amener au final
tout le monde est là tout le monde
revient à signaler dr les benini
commande d'atol et tout le monde va bien
merci à tous merci venez venez venez
tous voila